mystère deviner qu'il fait encore la
coupe de coeur je préfère donner lorsque
ou souris mutées sur le choix à la
police municipale de marseille de
marseille dans le sud et l'est je n'ai
pas une petite clara ici et là faut pas
trop s'attacher puisque moi dans
l'enquêté au raid tu me retrouve le taxi
et j'oublie tout des infractions
pourraient peut-être faire équipe tous
les deux ans comme dans bad boy donc
c'était vraiment une histoire pendant
que c'est une légende à marseille
belga à calais c'est toi qui me stresse
tu mets la pression aussi la ste plein
consentement l'abonné
ça faisait tellement longtemps on a un
problème s'avère vitale j'ai bien aimé
cette opération martyre le sol italien
je connaisse à marseille c'est rachid
[Musique]
bravo aux incas reprennent du service
j'ai voulu faire une petite santé
[Musique]
bon c'est parce qu'il est content